i will be talking to you about some work
i've been doing over the last kind of
many years now
um i generally work on data that are not
independent or identically distributed i
work a lot on spatial causal inference
so
in what i will be talking to you today i
don't want you to think of any of the
variables as um
independent across units and all the
random variables that i will be talking
about today have some spatial structure
in the sense that observations that are
nearby in space have more similar values
than observations that are further away
in space
now uh that can be problematic in some
settings but in the settings that i will
talk to you today they can be useful in
relaxing the non-measured compounding
assumption
i believe
so this is work that spreads two papers
with
corey ziegler christine shortage and
patrick schnell
all right but
before i talk to you about unmeasured
spatial confounding i want to talk about
a little bit about the term spatial
confounding and that's because in
spatial in the spatial statistics
literature and in the causal literature
this term is used to represent you
completely different
um
notions
so in spatial statistics
the goal will be different than what it
is in causal inference so we have to be
careful about when we talk to people
that are in in different parts of the
statistics world about
making sure that we have the same
language when we talk to them
now in everything that i will be talking
to you today i will be using z to
represent a treatment
i live in the potential outcomes world
so y i z will be the outcome observed
for location i had been exposed to
treatment z the measured outcome will be
assumed to satisfy the consistency
assumption and we also have a vector of
measure covariance c
now in spatial statistics what spatial
service study stations offer want to
know is the relationship between an
exposure and an outcome
and often what they care about is
understanding the relationship between
your exposure z with the outcome y
conditional on their measured variables
now if you had uh remember everything is
spatial so if you have z y and c and you
fit this regression model a lot of times
the residuals you'll get from this
regression will be spatially correlated
so if you do this
then your assumption that the residuals
are uh independent is violated and
spatial statisticians of course don't
like that because they want to make
inference on their coefficient so often
what they do is that they include a
spatial random effect in that regression
with the idea that that spatial random
effect is going to absorb all of the
spatial correlation and the residuals
and now their inference on the
coefficient of the exposure will be
correct
but what happens in reality
is that because this spatial random
effect has a spatial structure
and your exposure also has a spatial
structure these end up being collinear
so the coefficient of z in the
regression with a random effect and
without a random effect does not have
the same interpretation
so this is what in spatial statistics
they use to um
they think when they when they talk
about spatial confounding
their goal of estimation
is the conditional relationship between
y and z given c and when they put the
spatial random effect in there that acts
as a confounder in that it blurs the
relationship between y and c given c
given the measure covariance
now there's literature in spatial
statistics that discuss this discusses
this problem
now in causal inference though
we have a kind of like different
notion of spatial confounding
so for us what confounding is
it essentially means that we have to
adjust for some variables if we want to
estimate a causal effect
so what that means here in in the way
that i like to think about special
confounding
is that in fact the relationship that we
want to learn is a relationship the
conditional relationship between z and y
when we condition on some variables l
that satisfy the classic non-measured
compounding assumption but these random
variables l include the measured
variables but also necessarily need to
include some unmeasured spatial
variables as well
so there is this spatial random variable
u
that is a confounder of the y of the z y
relationship and we need to adjust for
it if we want to estimate causal effects
so this is a kind of like a crucial
difference between special statistics
and causal inference
so if you have if you want to estimate
essentially if you want to learn the
causal effect of z and y you need to
condition on all of the confounders
but you don't have access to all of them
you only have access to a subset of them
c
so what you can do well the first thing
you can do is you can try to fit this
this model that doesn't adjust for the
uh spatial compounder at all
and because it doesn't account for all
of the confounders this will not have
this will not give you something with a
causal interpretation
but also if we
like borrow from the spatial literature
and we try to include a spatial random
effect in this regression model this um
spatial random effect he cannot learn
it's different this u here will be
different from the actual confounder
this will be used to essentially try to
absorb the spatial correlation and the
residuals but it won't be the confounder
of the zy relationship so none of those
two models
can actually learn the causal effect of
interest and we need to actually have
the unmeasured confounder u if we want
to actually estimate the causal effect
so i wanted to start with this because i
don't know i mean i know this is a
causal inference group so i know that
perhaps facial confounding is a term you
haven't heard before but a lot of times
when i talk to people that have exposure
to special statistics the thing of
special confounding is a completely
different thing than what i think
spatial compounding is
so spatial statistics and causal
inference when they talk about spatial
confounding they have these two
completely different notions
but i mean the common thread is that
uh in both of these literatures we talk
about confounding as something that
blurs the relationship that we want to
estimate it's just that for us
an unmeasured special confounder is
something that we need to explicitly
adjust for if we want to estimate causal
effects
now if that unmeasured unmeasured
confounder
is
does not have any structure so if we had
iid data
we need to um
there's not much necessarily that we can
do there this is up for debate at least
not without assumptions but here i want
to talk to you about the situation where
this unmeasured variable has this
spatial structure and how we can
actually use that spatial structure
information to learn that and measure
variable and adjust for it
so these types of problems uh i have
been working on kind of like different
applications but one of the the the
application areas that i've been working
on a lot is air pollution epidemiology
now in air pollution there's been a
variety of regulations that have taken
effect over the last few decades in the
united states to reduce air pollution
from various sources power plants being
one of them
power plants can follow different
strategies to reduce emissions and one
of them is to install this scr and sncr
systems on their smoke stacks so
essentially you have a power plant it
emits this really dirty air they put a
filter there to make the air the
emissions a little bit cleaner
so the idea is that these scr's and cr
systems they reduce nox emissions and
because noximations are a precursor of
ozone the idea is that because nox
emissions go down ambient nozome
concentrations will also go down
so we want though to use data to
evaluate this relationship
and in air pollution epidemiology most
of the random variables we deal with are
spatial in nature so here i'm just
showing you pm 2.5 concentrations across
the new england and there's this spatial
trend in the sense that again nearby
observations have more similar values of
pollution than um
than not
so we also expect that the confounders
of the of this relationship might be
spatial in age so this is the situation
that i'll be talking to you later where
the treatment is binary
and there might be unmeasured spatial
variables
we have another application
where the treatment here is continuous
you can take values from 0 to 100 and it
represents the percentage of a
population in a county
that doesn't have access to supermarkets
and the belief is that if you don't have
access to supermarkets you don't have
healthy eating habits and that might
that might lead to subsequent problems
with
your cardiovascular health and here
again potential confounders can be a
number of different things
but they generally are expected to be
spatial in nature
so i'll be talking to you well depending
on time on how we can address
how i think spatial information and the
fact that we can assume that these
confounders are spatial can help us
adjust for them
now in the first case with a binary
treatment we are extending propensity
score matching to what we call distance
adjusted prevents discard imaging
so our estimate of interest is the
average treatment effect on the treaty
that represents
how much the treatment changed the
outcome among those that actually
received it now if we want to estimate
something like the att and i'm sure i'm
talking to you so this is great i could
go really fast
if all if all of your uh
if all of your confounders were measured
you could estimate the propensity score
much of that protects the score
but now not all of the confounders are
measured we also have some that are
unmeasured and we also want to adjust to
adjust for them
so the idea here is that okay you can
estimate something like a proxy
propensity score that have that has the
measure covariates
and that propensity score will balance
essentially you can think about it this
way or we'll bring the measured
covariance of treated and control pairs
closer together but you also want to
bring
you also want matches of treated control
units that are nearby in space because
they're they're also nearby in space
that a measured spatial variable will
also have similar values
so we combine propensity score
difference and spatial proximity
essentially in one measure that is
called the distance adjusted propensity
score so when we have a 3d unit i and i
control unit j with a small value of
dapps that will mean that the propensity
scores will be similar
and this
and the treated and control unit will be
nearby in space so their spatial
confounder will also have similar values
and this uh parameter w controls how
much weight we want to give in the
measure variables compared to the
unmeasured variables
so i like this little kind of like your
graph that i think
it shows you that if you think of this
line as being w that weight
the larger the w is the more weight is
given on the measured variables the
smaller w is the more weight is given on
the spatial variables
so we are somewhere on this line where
to choose w we have to kind of like
navigate this trade-off of how much we
want to balance the measure of variables
versus the unmeasured variables
and i will not talk to you today about
how we actually implement this but i
wanted to show you these two plots at
the top
that show balance of the covariates as a
function of w and the variables on the
left
are variables that are not expected to
be spatial
and the variables on the right are
spatial variables
so the spatial variables on the right
we can think that the standardized
difference of means is essentially flat
irrespective of what value of w w we use
so these spatial variables will be
balanced either based on the propensity
score or based on spatial proximity
however for the variables on the left
that don't have a spatial structure
they need a larger value of w to get
balanced
so we actually see
the interplay between the different
values of w as a priority is
prioritization for measure and
for uh spatial and non-spatial variables
and when we don't
account for space in the matching we see
matches that can be extremely far away
but when we do account for space we can
we see something that is more reasonable
reasonable
now we use
dabs we use naive propensity score
matching name meaning that it doesn't
incorporate space and we use a couple
other approaches to estimate the effects
of interest
and we saw that essentially all of the
methods
indicate that scrs and cr systems reduce
nox emissions
so because they reduce nox emissions and
because nox is necessary for creating
ozone we would expect that reducing nox
emissions
should not be let's not be leading to an
increase in ozone because that that
relationship would be backwards
however the analysis that that does not
account for space this naive analysis
shows that scis and cr systems reduce
nox emissions but increase ozone
which is backwards than what experts
would would expect to be true
but when space is being incorporated in
all these three methods
we actually see that even though scr's
and cr systems
seem to be reducing knox emissions they
don't seem to have an effect on ambient
noise and concentrations which is more
realistic than the analysis that doesn't
incorporate space
now this was
kind of like a
i i think that this is what you gain by
how by assuming that the unmeasured
compounder is spatial is that somehow
you can take advantage of geographic
proximity to somewhat adjust for it
but that approach
uh was somewhat causal for spatial
statisticians is that it had problems
discourse and spatial study stations
generally tend to like outcome
regression
so we worked with patrick on another
paper that
used outcome regression tools to adjust
for and measure spatial compounding
now i will
um
talk to you about this approach in terms
of um so we assume the potential
algorithms have this form
where
uh the treatment and the measure
covariates can be interacting in in
weird ways or in arbitrary ways but
there is no interaction between these
unmeasured variables
and the major variables or the treatment
now this can be relaxed but this is a
framework that we considered
now in what follows
i'm renaming this g of w as u and now
i'm thinking of this
the contribution of all of the
unmeasured variables
i don't care about what they are
explicitly all i want is that i account
for that for that full full function
view
and because and even though um
this isn't necessary and we have
extended this in the paper today we'll
be talking to you about the situation
where this there's there are no measured
variables
and the relationship between the
exposure and the outcome is linear and
again that's not necessary but this is
for ease of presentation
and in this specific situation
this coefficient essentially is the
treat is a corresponds to um the
treatment effect of increasing the
exposure by one unit
all right so if
this is the case i still don't have
um
i still don't have any data on this u or
these unmeasured variables but if i did
and i could fit the model that regresses
y on z and u i could estimate the causal
effect without bias but i don't have
data on you
i have just z and y and again you could
have measured variables but i don't want
to con i don't want to
complicate this uh
for no reason
so you have z and y
what you could do
is you could regress y and z and here
again you're not controlling for the
unmeasured spatial variables so this
will be biased
you could try to incorporate a spatial
random effect that's what spatial
statisticians would be doing and then
you would get the weighty squares
estimator here
get a tilde and if you look at both of
those and you look at the bias terms for
both of those
both of these bias terms will be
non-zero and the the fact that they're
non-zero arises from this conditional
expectation of the unmeasured variable
given the treatment
so essentially the it's pretty
um
kind of like easy thing to think about
it's to say well okay here's my bias
what if i subtracted that bias term
so this part over here
without the expectation of u given z
would be the weighted least squares beta
tilde so we subtract the bias term to
make this better over over line this
affine estimator we call it unbiased
so if we're able to identify this
conditional expectation of u given z
then we'd be able to do this bias
correction due to the unmeasured special
variable
and in general if u is not spatial
we could never learn that
but the fact that u is spatial and it
has some structure some correlation
structure across our observations means
that we can
take information from the exposure and
the outcome model residuals and learn
that conditional expectation
this is what i'm going to try to
convince in the next slide well first i
have to tell you what assumptions we
make about the conditional relationship
between you and z to achieve that
so if we assume that you and z
are multi form of a multivariate normal
distribution
and again this can be conditional and
covariates if you want it to be so
that um
so you could have a mean structure here
of for the z variable that depends on
measure variables
then we parameterize the the covariance
matrix of u and z in terms of in terms
of its precision matrix well we use the
precision matrix to describe these
relationships and we make the following
assumptions
first we make a cross markov property
assumption that says
that the only value of u that matters
for the exposure is the local value
that allows us to essentially
that implies that the q matrix here the
the cross
um
precision
is diagonal
we also assume that the the correlation
between u and z conditional and
everything else is constant across the
locations now both of those can be
relaxed
but the more you relax is the more
efficiency you lose
and
i am not going to um
to talk too much about this because i
hopefully if i have um time i will
describe them when i show you a graph
and again i'm not going to talk too much
about this but i want to talk about
where does this
where do these parameters these spatial
parameters come in
if we look at the likelihood of our data
our observed data is z and y if we look
at the other likelihood when we
integrate this and measure special
confounder out we see that in the mean
structure for y we have this term over
here that repre that corresponds exactly
to the expectation of u given z which is
again
this will be the the the uh the term
that drives the bias so if we have this
quantity over here if we can estimate
this quantity over here which is the
expectation of your given z then we'll
be able to add this back in and acquire
an unbiased estimator for for beta1 for
the causal effect of interest
so we want to estimate these spatial
parameters and if we know these spatial
parameters and again g and q are these
uh
the our um
um the variance covariance of u given z
and and and the
the cross relationship between u and z
then if we can learn these parameters
then we can do the bias correction and
if we look at where the information is
coming through to estimate these things
we see that the spatial structure in u
leads to a spatial structure in the
residuals for the exposure and also a
term over here this g inverse that has
to do with a spatial structure of u that
also manifests in the spatial residuals
for the outcome mode
i know that this slide is a lot but
essentially it says that if we can learn
the spatial parameters for you and the
relationship that you the that u has
with z then we can do this bias
correction
and now i hope that i can give you the
intuition of why we can actually do this
instead of uh throwing any math in this
so
imagine that you have data on a ring
graph so essentially all the spatial
dependencies are represented by um
by connections of uh
random variables on this on this plot
over here so essentially ui is
correlated with ui minus one
ui plus one is um
conditional on all the values of u
or all the other values of u ui plus 1
is independent with ui minus 1.
so i want to learn
the spatial parameters that drive these
relationships so rho
is the conditional correlation between u
and z in the same location
and field view are the parameters that
drive the spatial correlation of the
spatial the spatial confounder
so if i can learn row and phi of u then
i can learn some of the spatial
parameters that i'm interested in
so if we look at the conditional
relationship of pairs of z that are two
lags apart so look at z i plus one and z
i minus one
conditional on z i
if these two guys are correlated
it necessarily means that there will be
some path backwards like this that
drives this correlation
because conditional on zi minus one z i
this these two should be independent
unless there's a spatial random variable
and that correlation has to do with
row
one fee of u another few of you and
another row
if zi plus one and zi minus one so here
they're uh they have one zi between them
if they had two zi's between them so
they were
they were a distance three instead of a
distance two then they would have row
figu another for you another figure in
row
if there were four if there were a
distance four they would have two rows
and four figures if they were a distance
five they would have two rows and five
figures so essentially by looking at the
uh of how
the the conditional correlation of
perseverance at different lags decays
you can understand how the spatial
correlation of the unmeasured special
confounder like what the structure of
this measure special compounder is
so we proved this for ring graphs but we
think that it can be extended to the
situation where as long as we have
enough pairs at varying lags we believe
that this identifiability will also hold
and in the paper we also show that if
you is not spatial
then we cannot identify the causal
effect of interest which is not
surprising because if you can if you
don't have a spatial structure of the
unmeasured on the unmeasured confounder
then you can never learn the bias term
we use this methodology to estimate the
causal effect of cardiova of access to
to grocery stores and cardiovascular
disease and
the models
that did not adjust for space
showed that
if people have less access to
supermarkets that reduces the risk of
cardiovascular issues which is backwards
of what we would expect
so it shows a protective effect of
limited grocery store access
when space is accounted for either
through the weighted least squares that
just includes a spatial random effect
well then we see
an effect that is essentially null with
a relative risk that is centered
essentially a1
when we
use the alpha estimator that tries to
explicitly account for the unmeasured
special variable
that effect
moves a little bit to higher to higher
values than one but it's still not
statistically significant but at least
these effect estimates are more in light
with what we would expect in with
subject matter knowledge than than not
all right so
um
i talked to you a little bit today about
spatial statistics and causality about
how the the two fields might have
similar goals but they go about it
completely in a completely different way
um i do believe that
uh
structured data either that structure
comes from spatial or network settings
it can be
it can create problems and challenges
and statistics but also can create
opportunities and i think that this
what i'm presenting you today is
essentially an opportunity where having
structured data where not having a
random sample but having dependencies
can help us gain something instead of
complicating something else
now the
the identifiability we the results we
had here they hinge on spatial
correlation the heat on this structure
and they exploit exactly this this
structure
so um
i have the data if you want if you're
looking for data for your projects my
data i just generally try to make them
publicly available
so um
yeah these are my references and thank
you for listening
great thanks we'll take the questions
during the panama session and we have a
half an hour break
okay